there is absolutely nowhere here that's
been spared
street after street it's the same
shattered buildings and bomb craters
the front-line city of sierra donetsk is
a key target for russian forces
and it's been under attack since day one
of this invasion
the people here survive on handouts
there's no power or running water
most have left and those staying only
come up from their basements when the
shelling stops
you've been down here since the
beginning
82 year old valentina leads me back down
into the darkness
more than 20 people are living in this
cramped space
but even here
there is some hope
you should
what little they have to eat is
carefully stored
and you might think a city would give up
in the face of all this but the
resilience here is staggering
at the main police station the ukrainian
flag still flies proudly
this building's been targeted again and
again but the resistance remains strong
this is the second floor
of the police building it's still very
much
under ukrainian control but this area is
heavily contested at the moment
and there isn't really any part of this
city
that hasn't been hit by
russian attacks
this was an airstrike
now nobody was killed incredibly and the
police are managing to still work
out of the rest of this building
but it's a scene of absolute devastation
everyone in this city is struggling in
the face of unrelenting savagery
as we visit the only working hospital
the sound of fighting gets closer
inside the medics do what they can
they're treating the war wounded and
routine emergencies people don't stop
getting sick because they're shooting
outside
all of the patients are treated in the
corridors away from the windows which
have been blown out by shells
this hospital has been attacked more
than 20 times
is recovering from shrapnel wounds but
she's defiant and has this message for
vladimir putin
and after we left we received these
images from medics
the hospital had been shelled again and
one of the patients was killed
it is another reminder of the brutal
nature of russia's war
where the innocent are all too often the
victims
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine